[Music]
good evening
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and thank you all for coming out
federal government often gets the most
detention
and strangely it's the local and the
state governments
that have the most power and effect on
our lives that's especially true in the
recent weeks it's also why i'm very
excited to welcome our speaker tonight
michael tubbs who
started his career as the youngest mayor
in the country and did some of the most
radical and interesting experiments in
local government that we've seen so far
welcome michael tipps
well first good evening um so so good to
see you all and i want to start our
conversation today
um with an acknowledgement that is such
an incredible privilege
to have the space
to have the time
to have the mental capacity
to think about the future we know that
brain science tells us that poverty and
facts
and makes it difficult to do long-term
thinking
that for the six million californians
living in poverty or the 37 million
americans living in poverty not to
mention those for a one paycheck one
sickness
one covet diagnosis away
from losing two weeks of work and being
plunged in poverty themselves that this
idea of long-term thinking is something
that neurologically is very difficult to
do because it impacts sort of the
ability of their brain to think and plan
long term so i want to center our
remarks on the future
with the acknowledgement that the future
we deserve is impossible to build
without everyone being part of building
it i submit to you as i start our
conversation today
that a lot of people today
in san francisco and stockton and los
angeles throughout the state and
throughout this country
are living a nightmare in the present
that's a result of someone's dream of
the past and what the future could look
like if we don't want to repeat the
mistakes of the future then we have to
make sure that everyone has the ability
to be part of what the future for our
great state and for our country and our
society looks like
and i also stand before you today i
think
as one of many examples of what the
future can look like
32 years ago i was born in poverty in
one of the poorest cities in the state
stockton california with a mother who
was 16 and a father who still is
incarcerated and 32 years later i get to
give talks about the future
i was a mayor i get to advise the
governor and i say that to say that
we're missing on so much potential
so many dreams of what our society could
be like
because so many people are trapped in
the present and i just submit to you
today that the future we deserve that
the future we need that the ability to
imagine a society as it should be
predicates on the decisions we make
today particularly around the issue
of poverty and the avoidable impairment
of basic human needs in our state in our
country
and when i think about sort of how do we
design the future or what does the
future look like i think of a story my
grandmother taught me
my grandmother is the holiest person i
know what's today thursday wednesday
she's probably at church or watching
church if it's there any days of the
while my grandmother's at church and
growing up
um she taught me this parable but i
think everyone knows pretty well she
said one time there was a guy
walking
down the road and as he was walking he
was beat up
left on the side of the road to die he
just got hijacked ambushed he got robbed
and she said that a
priest walked by
and saw the man on the side of the road
and said well hmm
maybe god ordained for this person to be
on the side of the road
maybe there's nothing that can be done
maybe that's divine that this particular
person was on the side
of the road
and then she said another person walked
by maybe it was a politician
um walked by
saw the man on the side of the road
and said clearly this man chose
to be on the side of the road
if this man wasn't lazy
maybe he could pick himself up by his
bootstraps and get up
from the side of the road maybe if this
man was smart
he could find a way to get a job to pay
for a horse so he could get up from the
side of the road that that if maybe this
man had worked harder in school or if
this man
had been at the right place after if he
had just made better choices
he would not be left on the side of the
road
and then she said as samaritan came by
and saw the man
on the side of the road and sort of
got down from his horse got down
it's probably a woman actually think of
the story like it's a
good scenario samara woman she got down
on the side of the road
um bandaged his wounds made sure he had
a nice room at the presidio hotel and
made sure he was he was good in in and
on his way and i think oftentimes
when we think of policy
that or if you think about the future we
think the future requires all of us to
be good samaritans
and i submit to you today that even
that's not enough
and that's not enough because if you
look at the road in which the story took
place at jericho road it's a narrow road
that's conducive for ambushing
the road is known as the bloody past
meaning that a person on the side of the
road wasn't abnormal
but a person on the side of the road
wasn't surprising
that in fact by design the road was
designed in such a way for there to be
people left on the side of the road and
i submit to you as we think about the
future it's not enough to to think about
being good samaritans it's not enough
and it's important for all of us to
understand our common humanity it's not
enough to to believe in this notion of
universal human dignity but we have to
do the hard work of restructuring the
road because again this road was
structured for violence
that no one should be surprised to see
person on the side of the road when
there's easy places for robbers to hide
in ambush where it's narrow and it's
hard to get help and i submit to you
today as we think about the future the
president is a good teacher and that all
the outcomes we complain about
to the crime you guys talk about in the
drug use in the tenderloin to to the
educational outcomes we see there was
just a smashing grab at the chanel store
in l.a yesterday that all these things
are actually predictable
based off how our society in the present
is structured
and that's what i tend to call the setup
so i'm gonna spend a couple minutes just
to list a couple of the actions of
government
of the folks we vote for the things we
pledge allegiance to that have created
the outcomes we complain about and so
bear with me as we go through a little
history lesson
on what we know in terms of
that the present we inhabit was based
off actions of the past and we know that
in 1492 some folks came over here
and displaced a whole nation of millions
of people indigenous people and stole
their land
we know that in addition to that land
theft and genocide there was also 400
years of human trafficking
400 years of free labor that created the
wealth and created many of the
industries we enjoyed today and helped
submit america's standing as the leader
of this current world order we know that
even after that we had years of
redlining where certain neighborhoods
where certain people left had homes that
were deemed less valuable just because a
banker made a red line that said you
can't invest here you can't invest there
we know that during the great depression
when that everyone felt there was a new
deal that was struck and that deal
said that some people
can get gi benefits even though all
people
served in war that some people would be
able to go to college that some people
will get housing loans that some
industries would get new deal benefits
and that some people wouldn't and we
know that hundreds of years later we
have a a wealth gap between the races
that hasn't changed since 1964.
we know hundreds of years later
the same people who had their land
stolen from them
have terrible outcomes we know hundreds
of years later the same people who
worked for free for 400 years and were
trafficked and raped and brutalized
have terrible outcomes we know that 400
years later we have those same folks
doing similar types labor in our prison
system
fighting fires
doing municipal services all for below
the minimum wage and we know that if you
look at any indicator
of success and in the indicator of
failure if i showed you a picture if i
showed you a neighborhood if i showed
you a street
everybody in here to where t could guess
which
what's successful quote-unquote and
what's not and then i'll submit to you
today what i describe
as a draconian present
is because of the imaginations of those
that are able to create the future that
we inhabit today but but the point of
this talk is to give cause for optimism
and what i'm optimistic about
is this idea
that we can redesign the road in the
future
that we don't have to have a road or a
society or a country structured for
inequitable and equal outcomes that
there's literally things we can do
not with a magic wand
but with hard work and with truth to
create a future again that we all
deserve to live in
and before going to the policy
prescriptions let's talk about the truth
because we also know that in our society
a big part of the way this road is
maintained and graveled and made sure it
stays the way it is are the lies or the
narratives we tell about how we came to
be
we know it's hard to solve the issue of
poverty
if the ubiquitous thought is that people
are poor because they want to be poor
we know it's impossible to create a
future free of poverty when we believe
that people are poor because they're
dumber than people with money
we we know it's difficult to imagine or
create a world or a future free of
avoidable impairment of basic human
needs
when we believe that somehow that
there's a natural order to things that
somehow this hierarchy of human value we
tolerate in our society is okay so the
first thing we have to do when thinking
about the future is tell the truth and
the truth is this
talent and intellect are truly
evenly distributed but resources
opportunities are not
the folks i went to school with at
stanford weren't necessarily smarter
naturally biologically genetically than
the folks i grew up with in stockton but
they had the best schools the best
teachers the best summer enrichment
programs the the best tutors for 20
years
after already being born with an
insurmountable head start we know that
the truth is that we list miss out on so
much
just recently in the new york times
there's an article about the einstein
called the einstein effect and it talks
about how high performing and mass
low-income children
were less likely to get inventions and
patents than the worst performing rich
children
and that's not a question of merit
that's not a question of ability that's
a question of inputs resources and in
structure but that is something that
that we're able to change and we know on
the policy front what works particularly
for the issue of not having money
and it's not
teaching people how to manage money they
don't have
it's not mentorship
it it's not um unpaid labor
it it it's not a a minimum wage that is
lower than the cost of living in every
city in this country
but it is cash
and one of the things i did in the in
the old days when i was still an elected
official was we gave people money
and this was in 2017
before the pandemic
before my good friend andrew yang before
we had 80 mayors as a part of marriage
for guaranteed income before we had 100
guaranteed income pilots going on in
this country before san francisco had 12
pilots happening here in the city and it
came from this realization number one it
came from the imagination
of someone who grew up in poverty
it took someone who grew up in poverty
to start the first basic income program
in the country and i just want to pause
there for a second because i think it's
again it's incredibly important in this
conversation about the future to
understand that those
most impacted by the problem
have solutions
they have answers they have the radical
imagination needed to liberate us from
from from some of the nightmarish lies
we've all internalized it was really
that lived experience that gave birth to
this idea that let's try giving people
money and what we saw is is no surprise
because people are people
we saw that people spent money the way
you and i spend money because people are
people they spent the money on their
kids
they spent their money on utilities they
spent their money on food and they spent
their money on getting their uniforms
clean and we also saw that the money
did not make people stop working
wow
the 500.00 was not enough for people to
stop working instead what we saw is that
people were able to work more
because we saw that for folks living on
the margins for folks living in poverty
that 500 dollars was a difference
between affording child care or not
that 500 was a difference between be
able to get your car fixed or not that
500 was the difference from being able
to take time off your job
where you don't have paid time off so
you can't go interview for a better job
without the risk of losing money and say
you know how to bet on myself
and go ahead and do
an interview and get a full-time job
that pays more and allows you to work
less as we saw
time and time again and five years later
now we have again 80 mayors who are
saying yes let's figure out what
guaranteed income looks like we had a
child tax credit
which cut child poverty in half and
somehow folks in dc thought that was a
bad idea and so let's
with inflation coming let's cut this in
the child tax credits to make all the
kids poor again we have momentum around
this idea and i think the future has to
be one where we all agree that no one
should be poor that
no one
should live in poverty that no one
should be homeless and if those sounds
like radical notions
they're not because you don't live in
poverty
you don't live in scarcity
you don't live unhoused and unsheltered
so if it's good enough for you
it should be good enough for everyone
that's not saying everyone needs the
same
but it is to say like what type of
future would we have
if not one that understands that
everyone has the same basic human value
and everyone needs at least a baseline
level of security to be human
that everyone needs at least the basics
shelter
food
water the ability to pay bills and again
we have policy tools that work and the
question is how building the political
will to get there and again i think that
goes back to the narratives around how
do we talk about the present
and how do we talk about the future and
who do we allow to participate
in the conversation around planning for
the future
another policy solution we can do that
will literally end the wealth gap in
this country
will be baby bonds it's been researched
it's been
theorized there's literally bills and
state legislature just literally bills
in the u.s senate now that says if you
put just a little bit of money a little
bit of seed money in a child's account
when they're born
you let it grow children have assets so
that the mistakes of the past don't have
to dictate or or or narrow their future
and and again we know what it can do
there's been models there's really bills
in congress now there's a bill in the
state legislature that just passed at
least for kids with covert but this is
something we can do today to prepare for
a future where if there's gaps in wealth
they're truly gaps based off ability if
there's gaps in wealth they're truly
based on gaps in effort
not based off gaps in government
intervention not basing gaps of
marginalization but but that's really
based off merit and i think
i'm having this argument with one of my
friends who thinks about the future
differently than i do
is that what i'm
saying we should want for the future
isn't equal outcomes
but just ones i'll say it again it's not
about
equal outcomes it's about just outcomes
it's about outcomes that are
predicted by the just inputs we put in
and not these wild outcomes we pretend
are based off merit that we pretend are
based off ability that we pretend are
based off how everyone's working because
that creates the dysfunction all the
isms the anxiety the the stress
um that that plagues our society are far
too often today so as i draw to a close
i i would say that
i am more optimistic than ever
the more i think about the future
for a couple of reasons
reason number one
being this idea that
this present was created by people
this present was created by folks who
had dreams and imaginations and values
now i think if we stick to what we say
our values are or as dr king said if we
stay true to what we say on paper we can
really build a future that looks like
our values of opportunity of liberty and
of justice for all and and number two
i'm incredibly
um optimistic about the future because
for all the ways in which the present
isn't what we want to be
sometimes i i get heartened with
thinking about
the past was even worse
like for all the ways in which
um it feels like we're moving backwards
from the the very real consequences of
the roe v wade decision recently
um to the very real consequences of
getting the voting rights sack to the
very real real consequences of
attempted coups and insurrections there
was actually a time in this country
where things were worse
um
and
things only got better
because people even mired in this
function of today
did what this foundation does did what
you all do and step back and said okay
but what can tomorrow be
and and also it's it's incredibly
inspiring because
we have the opportunity to bring other
people into that future planning process
to really speak from experience about
sort of how the future could look
different particularly for those on the
margins because the next invention to
make our life easier
it's not
on sand hill road
it's not
in the presidio it's probably some
little kid in hunter's point breathing
environmental toxins it's probably a
young person in south stockton hearing
gunshots at night it's probably a young
person in watts
i'm sleeping hungry that that when we
leave so much on the table
not just for today but for tomorrow
by allowing the mistakes and the
imagination of the past
dictate how we live in in the present so
as i conclude 10 years ago
i was on the freedom rides with some of
the original freedom writers
and it was i reflect on this often
because
these were like that i mean they're
older folks now but when they did this
they were 19 20 21 years old they
literally signed their wheel before
going on the bus
and and one guy looked at me we're going
through
we just lit we just left when the
penitentiaries in mississippi
and he looked at me and he said michael
i was arrested on august 4th 1961.
why is that day important and i said
well you were arrested if you weren't
arrested i wouldn't be here thank you
i'm so thankful for all the
opportunities like you you did that and
he looked at me
and he said no son on that day
barack obama was born
and then he said he had no idea
and that's what's so beautiful about
long-term thinking and future planning
and that's why
everyone needs to be a part of it
because there's something hopeful and
prophetic about it and he said he had no
idea that the choice he made on that day
would pave the way so that 50 years
later a child born with no opportunity
a child whose birth was illegitimate in
some states because his father was black
and his mother was white
would have the chance to be president
and then he looked at me and he said
what are you prepared to do today
so that 50 years from now a child born
in poverty has the opportunity to be
president and
i think that's really the question that
motivates the great work of this
foundation
it's not just about 50 years or 100
years but 10 000 plus years of magnitude
and the question really is it's not
going to be one person
or one dream
or one leader that's going to save us
it shouldn't be
10 people or 20 people that are planning
the future
can y'all imagine if it was just elon
musk about the future like what no
offense i'm sure some of his friends are
here he seems lovely um
[Laughter]
but um
but it's on each and every one of us
every day
to think about what our values are
and we line that up with the answer to
this question what are we prepared to do
today
so that 10 000 years from now there's a
society there's a country there's a
civilization
that looks back at this day and wonders
how do they think that
that looks back on this day and laughs
and say oh my gosh they allowed that to
happen
what are we prepared to do today so that
tomorrow
all the things that are imperfect today
seem silly
seem adequate and they in the bright
tomorrow that we create is something
that our future
descendants ten thousand years from now
viewed as inevitable
like how do we create a society that ten
thousand years from now
those who look as us as ancestors and
reading about us some history books
look like we look sometimes and say oh
yeah this was always going to change
this was always going to happen like
eventually they figured out that women
should have the right to choose full
stop that that no one should be poor
that no one should be hungry that no one
should be in house and that answer to
that question really lies in what we do
each and every day so thank you all for
what you're doing thank you all for what
you will do and looking forward to the
rest of our conversation
[Applause]
good evening
my name is michael mcafee and i'm going
to be in conversation with michael i've
got some questions from the audience and
we'll get more so if you have questions
write them down on the cards and i will
do my best to make sure that we get
through them
it's good to be with you brother always
good to you
i wanted to start with you you used a
word that i think
um is important when we think about lung
now thinking you use the word prophetic
and when we think about
poverty
when we think about what you do i want
to start with the person first
what do leaders need
to be able to do the prophetic work of
liberation because ending poverty
is a liberatory act
and so when you think about that what
advice do you have for us around
what do leaders need to do in their
person
to be prepared to do this work
and i know it's not absolute and it's a
journey but
what do you recommend we start no i'm
pausing because that wasn't the
questions you sent me so let me think
you know i had to just i am i'm just
ripping off warming up
no but but in all seriousness i i think
that um
part of it has to be disengaging from
what's possible yeah and we're having
the conversation before the talk about
how the impossible happens
and i actually think you have to look at
reality for what it is
and there's a delta between what it is
and what it should be
but you can't be dissuaded with how big
that chasm is or how big that delta is
and
marion wright elderman one of my mentors
she told me
when i was on city council and i was
already tired i'm like this is crazy
stuff i'm good like what's what how'd
you do this for so long yeah you know it
was like nearly my first year in city
council i was like how did you do this
and she said it's a privilege to
struggle for justice because you're not
by yourself a and it's a relay yeah so
even if you don't get everything done
in your turn
or everything done in your time you have
to trust that there's gonna be someone
else
to pick up the baton just like you were
the answer to someone saying he's gonna
pick up the baton for me and that that
so i think it's having that long now
thinking that's well that it's not just
you
but in the time you have
you have a role to play
and that role and what you do in your
imagination can't be tethered strictly
to what's what seems possible or
convenient or expedient which is what
people really mean when they say
possible it's like what's comfortable
and what's not sacrificial and what's
convenient
um but know that to get to where we need
to be that you have to take some swings
you might miss and and
i think you also though have to
when we had the first meeting for my
staff another one give people money and
my staff they act like they're on board
now they was like you crazy we're not
doing that right right
um and i told them i said but you guys
we have a responsibility if the status
quo is fine
let's find something else to do like
this is not fun if everything's okay i
want to do something else
um but if the status quo is untenable
then we have to do something we have to
try and innovate and experiment and be
willing to be wrong and to be willing to
lose so i think the answer to your
question after that
meandering jericho wrote it was
um
you have to be so
brene brown said like this she said you
have to be really concerned with getting
it right
versus being right
like getting it right like trying versus
having the answer and when you do that
it relieves some of the fear that gives
you the opportunity to explore because
again
the fact that you're experimenting means
no one has the right answer yet so
you're going to be just as right or
wrong as everyone else at the worst
at the best you can at least point a lie
as to what what what could work or what
could this a possible solution be that's
right
you know when you think about what you
did with guaranteed income
it is um
it moves beyond charity
and when you talk about upsetting the
setup
that upsets a lot it upsets the
nonprofit industrial complex
if we all fell in poverty we would not
say
um
tell me the 20 agencies i should go see
we would say let me have a little gas
keep it in my car let me keep my lights
on and let me do that
how do we go from where we are at now
where we have a charity mindset
we have that samaritan mindset versus
the mindset that is necessary to
reimagine government systems reimagine
non-profit systems to do the most
elegant thing which is directly put cash
in people's pockets
i really
believe
it it stems from
this and it's no one's fault we we we
grow up in a society where it's
programmed in us and
ingrained in us
that if folks have less something's
wrong with them
that they're the problem
and until we really recognize that even
behaviors are dysfunctional or behaviors
that are abnormal
are in effect and not the cause the the
the
effect of a dysfunctional society of
dysfunctional community of something
that was broken before the person was
broken and until we really get that
we'll continue to have these solutions
that again position the person as a
problem i say that because
before we're doing the guaranteed income
work
before we're doing the guaranteed income
work i actually had internalized some of
those thoughts myself
so when we first were thinking about it
before i committed to do it i had to do
some wrestling with myself like
can we really give these people like
don't get just give people money
it took me a while to think and in the
course of the interrogation i i again
had to challenge myself and say well
what
sort of biases have you picked up for
being in this be in this society and
and why
what about you
makes you better equipped to spend money
than someone you don't know that's right
well you know let's let's stay on the
ubi um
ken i believe it's broad asked the
question
um isn't the focus on ubi misplace
given that the cost of living is so high
here
shouldn't the focus be on cost of living
so
ubi or a guaranteed income
isn't a panacea
um
far from a magic bullet
and we have to be able to walk and chew
gum and do multiple things at once so
the the powerful thing about guaranteed
income universal basic income um
one of them is this idea of income
volatility
that
particularly if you are one paycheck
away or two paychecks away from poverty
your income is incredibly volatile
depending on on the circumstances
um it regards the cost of living like if
you're
tire bust if you're
kid is sick if you're
um
you need to take time off work etc
and the guaranteed income helps or
smooth that so it builds economic
resilience
um in in addition um there's
to deal with high costs of living you
could deal with the drivers which we
should that bring the cost of living up
you can also make sure people have more
money to help pay for those costs so i
think
in a way
as solutions go a guaranteed income
may be not a perfect solution but if
there's one thing to do maybe the best
solution to deal with
all the ways in which lack of cash makes
life difficult for folks
thank you
kevin kelly asked the question what
other solutions are there and i want you
to respond to something in relationship
to this question
sometimes when people ask me what are
other solutions i say the first solution
should be to stop harm
to see the systems of oppression that
are right in front of you that are
undercutting this good work say like a
municipality that chooses to
enact excessive fines and fees and poor
neighborhoods right things like that you
were talking about the design of
oppression
so what are some of the solutions and
how do you help people see
just the design of cities and states
that are automatically undercutting all
the good poverty work anti-poverty work
yeah um so the la times had a lot of
solutions are so simple the la times had
a really good article today
about homelessness
and
the shocking conclusion
um was that the biggest predictor of
homelessness in the community was
lack of affordable housing
[Music]
that um chemical dependency definitely
was an issue that's not clear if that's
the cause or the effect
um
that
mental health issues definitely
i'm an issue but the biggest predictor
of there's gonna be homeless folk or
folks that are homeless excuse me
was
lack of affordable housing so one
solution would be
build affordable housing and make it
affordable to build affordable
affordable housing um
we talked about baby bonds um another
sort of
solution
would be we we know
what the cost of living is or at least
what it costs to rent a one bedroom
apartment
and we know today that in 99 of counties
in the united states the minimum wage is
not enough to afford a one-bedroom
apartment
um so another solution would be
um a a minimum wage that allows people
to pay for minimums right like
yeah um
another solution is we have
sort of
particularly women who do caregiving
um in in domestic work if you do it
next door you could get paid but if you
do it in your house you can't
and then if you decide to work but you
work minimum wage
your entire check goes to child care
which is why so many women choose to
leave the work for our course to leave
the workforce to stay at home and not
get paid to do the hard work of
childbearing because they went and this
is like
pay child care workers enough
have
child care
count if you take care of and be paid if
you take care of your own children
um on the criminal justice reform like
we we know that
or let's do foster kids i know
homelessness is such a big issue we know
that 50 of all foster children will be
homeless at some point in their life
why is that are they born inherently
homeless are they born with an inherent
desire to live on the streets or is it
because they're kicked out of the system
when they're 18 with no supports and no
resources that's so a and and
the ant it sounds simple because it is
the answers are simple implementing them
is difficult don't get me wrong but like
the answer isn't a mystery like you
don't need a genie like the answers are
very clear it's just building the
political will
to do it because the answers aren't free
in some cases
um
but we also pay for
what we see like we spend trillions of
dollars on
poverty
every year
but there is a dominant logic to what
you're saying that is going to require
some long-down thinking to change
it was government that built the white
middle class gi bill fha those types of
things we now say government can't do
this we can't afford it so how do we
make this bridge you were talking about
not making the mistake when peter
was beautiful about that because i know
i was in a conversation with some other
folks about this and they thought i was
like attacking them
i said i've never been a hater i
understand government could do it for
you and your family let's look for
everyone's families like we know you
could do we know it can happen let's
let's do it for everyone like i love i
love that for you i do but let's do it
for for everyone right
yes um
so
but but i think to your question and and
i tried to talk about a little bit about
my remarks and probably should drill
down more but i think part of it is the
narratives like when we're talking about
long now thinking it's like what's the
mindset that you have
in you as you think about the future
because your mindset is one of scarcity
if your mindset is one of
again hierarchy if your mindset is one
of
sort of
the world is arranged the way it is
by
the invisible hand
of god and market
who just created all this craziness like
then the future's gonna look crazy it's
gonna look like this like right yeah but
on mars or something like what's that so
i i
i think we have to really do the work of
just really interrogating what we see
and really asking the question why but
it's so hard we're so busy and we're
working and we're building and we're
doing that to take a second instead of
like being mad
or angry or next door
um
you say well honey
how did this come to be if it's oh and
and then you say this and and as the
global black wall says this all the time
we also have to have relentless honesty
because i keep hearing nostalgia
for a time that never was
like i'm not like
like this again
like not like let's go back again let's
make this great again
when
and for who
yeah right because because and again to
the to the beginning of your question
there there's countless examples in our
country's history
where our country was great for some
folks it had great policies for some
folks and now the rub or the issue is
that how do we send that greatness to
all
and i think that's there's like a
narrative thing or i think a mindset
thing we have to really interrogate
because again the issue isn't capacity
or ability
we can do it the issue is around who's
deserving and who's not
and and and
and and
once you got yours should no one else
have any and i think that's the kind of
some of the fights we're having right
now
do you think we have enough pain for
getting to the all that solidarity you
know
here in the bay
no matter what color your skin
folks struggle even when they're making
good money because of
you know those sins of the past we we
abandoned the public good of
education
public education so now if you live in
the city you got kids you got to make a
choice can i afford private school or my
rent are my mortgage because
many cases you would say public
education is not the best option so i
have to pay for it
so do you think how much more pain do we
have to experience as
one path to getting to solidarity or is
there another path
that is a good question um
because it's actually wild how
widespread the pain is and how we still
have such polarization i'm like that
yeah i get it you can think about it
okay i hate my music but come on like
let's fix it like you poor i'm poor like
there's something in common
let's work on that um so actually
michael i i don't know i don't know
what it will take you would think a
global pandemic would do it
like
you would think like literally the stock
market crashing in a way like yes
literally like the biggest employers in
this country saying government we need
bail us out we have nothing yes you
think
um a summer of
people of all races taking to the
streets
saying black lives matter we have to be
better you you
i don't know what what what could be
worse like i don't i i'm scared about
what
like
where are the other options in terms of
what's what's enough for a wake-up call
yeah and i think that's why the work of
this foundation and the work that you
all do that policy link is so important
just to show people beyond like
being human and nice and kumbaya like
this is about survival that's right it's
about having a future
this is about having a country a
republic a democracy
so i'm gonna keep talking about it but i
actually don't know what it's going to
take but i hope it doesn't take too much
more i i i can't do more that's right um
of this craziness we need like i need
let's just fix it before it gets worse
that's right
well let's move into a little bit more
exploration of some of the solutions you
know leela asks us we we know
guaranteed income works
so
how do we overcome the objections to it
and and to piggyback on another part of
this question someone else asked
what cities do you think have the
greatest
promise
for having a breakthrough
so i turned down a job after i lost
re-election in the white house
because i looked and i said hmm
that senate doesn't look like it's going
to be the type of city that's going to
do things when you're done
um
and i said the
california there's no excuse
because you don't have
any opposition party it's
a one-party state
and
one party talks about being for liberty
and opportunity
and progressive and that which is small
with that
but highs for the poverty so much
housing unaffordability and sheltered
into people who are unsheltered etc so i
decided to stay in california to do the
work of in power of california and
marriage for guaranteed income based in
california
because i want to see it as a political
issue
is the issue that there's just a
political party who doesn't believe in
that or is the issue something else it's
the issue that regards the political
party there's a comfort with poverty
there's a comfort with hierarchy there's
a comfort with sort of some people doing
really really bad as long as i feel good
and that's what i'm trying to
interrogate so i'm very hopeful about
california actually because it's my only
hope um
in terms of how to get these things done
and and then i
think for all the answers to the
question about like we know what works
why not we know what works why not
there's probably a more
deliberate and didactic answer but i
think the short answer is
this country
our policymakers and our history
suggests that we are fine giving money
to some folks and not to others and
we're fine with some folks being poor
and that makes people very uncomfortable
to give money to
women
for example and in fact many people are
arguing that the
roe v wade decision and the assault on
the human rights of women are
particularly as women are making gains
and economic parity in the workforce
right like because they have agency over
over their body and decisions they make
or uncomfortable giving money to black
people because black people are lazy and
don't want to work and spend money on
alcohol and jordans
and people tell me that
people would tell me that all the time
with basic income they wouldn't say
black people they would say you know
people huh we're going to spend money on
like talk about me like yeah
that's how i got these you're right um i
spend money on shoes like you do you
have shoes on too anyway
um
or we're uncomfortable giving money to
like
immigrants or like
we just have a discomfort with
affording to some folks basic human
dignity and just the benefit of the
doubt that we do to others and that's
why for
like literally we ended a
child tax credit
yeah for like
for parents with children we said you
know what after we did it and it worked
we said you know what
despite what you said
i know in west virginia my folks are
spending the money on like joe really
anyway
it's supposed to be non-political slot
asked me these questions
well let me ask you this last political
one we're getting close to time but matt
thompson asked the question
if this was implemented how would it
change our politics so think of just
what you said in california how would
that change it
oh if which everything was implemented
yes let's say we were successful with
implementing guaranteed income oh just
guarantee that again i have a big list
how's okay
because we know we got to get to all of
that right yeah okay like if we if we
guarantee income i will retire and be
like you know what someone else can talk
now i'm good
when things off the list no um
it would change our politics because a
more people will be engaged because more
people will have positive interactions
with government
if you're economically insecure
etc
your relationship with government is
usually punitive it's usually you to
come to this court day it's usually you
have to get your car it's not to get
towed it's usually oh this bill etc
versus like oh my government sees me
believes in me i have it and we saw that
in some of the data in stockton that
people had a more positive think thought
about government i think it would also
help restore trust in institutions that
folks would be like oh okay
this thing works it's what it works for
me my my tax i see
more of my tax dollars coming to me and
that's a good thing i think it would
allow people to engage in politics we
know that in our country
money is a proxy for time i can't go to
city council meetings i can't go to this
commission i can't volunteer here and
volunteer here because i got to work
i got to eat i don't have paid time off
and i think and we saw
there's it's no surprise
or it shouldn't be a surprise
that
the most intense years of labor
organizing of unionization
have been the last couple yeah
because a there was a a pandemic but b
people had more agency because they were
had stimulus checks they had a child tax
credit they had to go to state stimulus
they were able to
more in a
more powerful
or palatable position to bargain and to
collectively bargain and to say you know
what actually i don't because
people always talk and one of the things
we should debate all the time was this
notion of the dignity of work yeah and
that like
you're digging yeah people
want to work because that's how they get
their dignity and what we've seen
is that actually people have inherent
dignity
and if you give people a floor it allows
them to negotiate to be treated with
dignity at work right and i think that's
how government would change what they
guarantee them
well we're at time i'm going to ask you
this last question and
as i asked you this question i invite
you to just leave us with a party and
reflection on what we can do to support
this work or anything else that you like
malcolm says and i'm going to read it
exactly as malcolm wrote it
he says have you thought about running
for governor senator
[ __ ] it president
to take your vision nationwide
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well thank you malcolm
so i was lucky enough to spend
eight years
in local government
in my good years my 20s
[Laughter]
party years i spent
no taco tuesdays i was like city
councilman
for hours
um
and and i say that to say i really
enjoyed it and
clearly i believe that government is an
important driver for a lot of these
things and
i turned 32 in two weeks
um
so
hopefully i've been working out and
stuff i have a lot of life ahead
so i'm not in any hurry
to run for anything again i actually
enjoy like
no i'm like to talk like this but i'm
still married too but in my head i think
i talk more freely no i'm not
elected so i i know that i'm committed
to working on these issues
but right now
it's outside of government which is fine
for now and
if it makes sense in the future to run
for something i would seriously consider
it but i
truly love
being ex-mayor
[Laughter]
hilarious brother
thank you will you all give
michael a hand
thank you
thank you
appreciate you brother
[Music]
you